ce sont parmi les plus fortes photo les
meilleures photos d'actualité de l'année
le world press photo
ça commence demain au marché bonsecours
à montréal et ça dure un mois
maxence bilodeau s'est intéressé
particulièrement un photographe qui est
allé en ukraine de les voir je vous
avertis je vous préviens tout de suite à
certaines photos qui sont très durs un
grand champ de blé est là
un passager inerte de malaysia airlines
encore attaché à son siège
parmi les premiers arrivés sur les lieux
le photojournaliste jérôme sessini
évidemment la première réaction c'est lé
froid l'apport même quelque chose
d'assez puissant 2
j'ai ressenti de la peur en voyant cette
heure de quoi en fait je sais diffus je
pourrais pas décrire exactement c'est
son métier il prend des photos
la difficulté pour moi c'était de
trouver la bonne distance pour donner à
mes photos je voulais c'est témoigner
décrire ce qui se passait mais sans
donner trop de
de détails
vous dire
je rendrai les photos papa pas
regardable en fait
celle là c'est vraiment la plus
polémique alors cette photo et
polémiques parce que là j'ai reçu
beaucoup d' insulte une photo qui montre
de corde un passager tombé du ciel qui
s'est retrouvé dans une chambre à
coucher
pourquoi vous vous tenez à ce que cette
pub c'est plutôt là soient publiés c'est
le summum de l'horreur moi c'est
l'horreur pour les victimes du vol c'est
l'horreur pour les personnes village
parce que j'ai rencontré les personnes
village elles sont traumatisés à vie
c'est génial et pour toutes ces photos
prises ailleurs dans le monde des
enfants qui meurent sous les bombes
israéliennes sur une plage à gaza des
adultes qui meurent du virus ebola en
afrique
toujours la même question publié ou
censurer ce qu'il faut pas le montrer
non je ne crois pas pourquoi ne pas le
montrer
si on commence à se censurer
ça devient très dangereux de passes
censuré s'est aussi montré un couple gay
partageant un moment d'intimité en
russie cette photo d'un danois a
remporté le premier prix du world press
photo ici maxence bilodeau radio canada
montréal